ce samedi à montigny le bretonneux se
déroulait la sixième édition de la
journée des possibles devant la
médiathèque organisé par une vingtaine
d'associations locales l'objectif était
de sensibiliser aux enjeux
environnementaux
elle est importante parce que il ya
encore des personnes qui ne savent pas
ce que c'est qu'une amap
et il ya des gens qui ne connaissent pas
encore le commerce équitable
donc on fait un travail de
sensibilisation
d'information
et on essaie de le faire de façon
ludique au programme de la journée la
présentation des actions locales des
ateliers de sensibilisation ainsi que
des jeux pour les petits et les plus
grands ont même tiré pendant qu'on veut
ouvrir - les enfants ça va comme portant
jusqu'à 77 ans de la
mais j'ai appris qu'elle grain
appartenait à quelles plantes j'ai
appris à peu près quelles plantes
conséquent en ce moment l'épaule foire
salah ben je crois
ce qui est important c'est de montrer
tout ce qui se passe au niveau
associatif et qui concerne la
préservation de l'environnement ont fait
il ya est quand même pas mal de dassault
sur l'agglo et finalement moi en tant
que membre d'une assemblée connaissance
je les connaissais pas tout et c'est
pour ça que je suis venu pour voir un
peu ce que font les autres prochain
événement organisé sous la bannière de
la fête des possibles le 29 septembre à
l'ermitage de versailles pour une soirée
ciné partage